je veux saluer d'abord une nouveauté
pour la première fois depuis
plusieurs décennies
nous sommes dans notre travaux à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
et nous le devons tu peux monter le
retour un peu je sais bien que on risque
du larsen mais
j'entends pas bien le
nous sommes dans nos travaux à l'heure
et nous le devons à une seule personne
qui va se lever ces maux de Gatel
[Applaudissements]
ça ne s'est jamais produit
mais vous comprendrez la phrase que je
vais dire
mode a été à bonne école
[Applaudissements]
et donc
j'étais très surpris par cette réalité
nouvelle et très heureux
de de cette discipline que nous avons
été capables de porter que tu as été
capable d'imposer avec une autorité
souriante mais non moins ferme
c'est modé notre nouvelle secrétaire
général dans une nouvelle équipe que
j'ai été très heureux de former et que
je suis très heureux de saluer alors
vous avez entendu Marc
à l'instant
j'étais très content marqué venu à Pau
la semaine dernière inaugurée une foire
agricole et j'étais très très fier pour
deux raisons
la première de ces raisons c'est que il
était
splendidement accueilli par le monde
agricole qui n'est pas un monde facile
qui est un monde totalement authentique
et un ministre de l'Agriculture
accueilli et aimé par l'univers dont il
a la charge c'est rare et vous pouvez
l'applaudir pour ça
[Applaudissements]
et puis parce que il a épaté tout ce qui
était présent par un discours
remarquable remarquablement construit et
remarquablement porté alors pour ça
aussi je veux lui dire merci parce que
c'est bien que le premier vice-président
de notre mouvement et cette faculté de
mobilisation
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais pas égrainer la liste des
vice-présidents mais comme il y a les
ministres puisque Geneviève et la
vice-présidente suivante donc je salue
les trois ministres après Marc
Geneviève Jean-Noël et Sarah
et je salue particulièrement Patrick
Mignola
à la fois
pour le travail qui a été le sien à la
tête de notre groupe
pour sa présence dans les médias et pour
le travail qui va être le sien dans la
responsabilité de responsable de tous
les porte-paroles du mouvement ils sont
là elles sont là plusieurs et donc je
suis très heureux que le combat continue
[Applaudissements]
ayant salué les parlementaires élus je
veux à mon tour saluer ceux qui se sont
présentés à cette élection soit qu'il
fut sortant soit qu'il souhaite entrer
et qui n'ont pas eu la chance que les
électeurs les choisissent on a fait une
fête très sympathique autour d'eux et je
voudrais vous demander de les applaudir
ce qu'ils n'ont pas eu la chance d'être
libre
alors je veux aussi saluer nos autres au
double sens du mot vous savez que le mot
hôte à la différence du mot test
grammaticalement il y a dans ce sujet
une discrimination les autres c'est à la
fois ce qui reçoivent et ceux qui sont
reçus
hôtesse ça marche pas pour
celles qui sont reçues donc nos hôtes
nos hôtes de Guidel à qui nous sommes
fidèles depuis 10 ans on a tant de
souvenirs dans ces murs
et temps de visage et y compris ceux qui
ne sont pas là et donc nos hôtes de
guidels de ce village vacances que je
voudrais vous demander de remercier par
vos applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
et puis ceux qui sont venus nous voir
alors je les citerai pas tous c'est
sûrement dans le désordre Jean-Yves Le
Drian Stéphane séjourné Edouard Philippe
Jean-Christophe combe François Braun
Gabriel Attal un mot particulier pour
Elisabeth borne qui est venu nous voir
jeudi et nous a apporté une lecture que
je trouve prometteuse de la de la
situation donc je la salue
particulièrement j'aurais aimé que
Richard Ferrand soit là breton alors je
lui adresse par l'intermédiaire des
ondes notre salut et notre affection
évidemment toute notre équipe alors
toute notre équipe que mode
a mis en vedette et notamment toute
notre équipe du siège
c'était une très bonne idée ça fait des
années que j'en rêve mais mes amis
savent que je ne les convainc pas à
chaque fois que je défends une idée même
si cette idée est évidemment la
meilleure
donc
il arrive qu'il Rejeb il se trompe assez
souvent
je veux dire simplement que
joindre les journées parlementaires et
notre université de rentrée c'est une
très bonne idée ça me rappelle ce qui se
passe dans les grandes formations
britanniques politiques britanniques qui
font un congrès par an avec les
parlementaires et avec les militants et
d'une certaine manière c'est ce que nous
sommes en train d'inventer de réinventer
dans ce Guidel plus qui est pour nous un
moment de rencontre de mobilisation je
suis très très fier avoir
près de 1000 personnes qui sont passées
pendant le week-end
plus de
750 participants payants ayant pris
chacun une part de la charge donc c'est
très important parce que je crois que
ministre militant
député militants sénateur militants
parlementaire européen militant
responsable militants et militants
militants
c'est une inspiration réciproque
on se transmet des raisons d'engagement
on se transmet des raisons de partager
une conviction et donc
évidemment c'est pour nous Jean-Paul tu
as Jean-Paul et moi
c'est une histoire plus longue que
Guidel donc
nous avons partagé beaucoup de combats
beaucoup d'engagement
sans imaginer jamais que ça pourrait
prendre cette tournure là et donc
et puis
j'ai particulièrement apprécié il est
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères
ce que Jean-Louis bourlange a dit hier
et dit tous les jours dans son analyse
insérer de la situation et donc pour
cette inspiration réciproque vous en
êtes les porteurs j'étais très frappé
parce qu'il y a une jeune femme que vous
aviez invité marque à la table ronde
agricole qui s'appelle Émilie Janin qui
est une
éleveuse de bovins et à la fin de la
table ronde elle a demandé la parole
pour dire quelque chose elle a dit
écoutez je suis absolument stupéfait
vous avez tous la banane
elle venait dans une réunion politique
elle avait l'impression que c'était des
gens qui étaient là un peu par force un
peu par fonction et elle a découvert que
dans nos rangs il y avait comme une joie
de vivre
qui n'est pas seulement une joie de
vivre qui est une joie d'engagement
qui est quelque chose qui qui nous
pousse à nous lever tous les matins et
dans les bons et dans les mauvais jours
à être là comme une force qui va
alors j'étais très frappé à elle a dit
vous avez tous la banane et ça donne de
l'espoir ça lui donner de l'espoir à
elle
et visiblement elle avait besoin qu'il y
ait comme ça une transfusion d'espoir
depuis une formation politique
alors moi j'ai pas seulement été frappé
par cette apparence ou cette réalité de
joie de vivre j'ai été frappé parce que
c'est un mouvement politique en pleine
épanouissement
avec des talents nombreux et des talents
en éclosion des talents en progression
et des talents en éclosion
et comme vous imaginez dans dans
l'histoire de ma vie c'est pas tout à
fait rien
cette ce pari fou
inimaginable à aller aux yeux de tous
les observateurs politiques
que l'on pouvait faire sauter les les
jeudis souvent les deux tours jumelles
des deux parties principaux qui
orientait commandait construisait la vie
politique française à droite et l'autre
à gauche et si c'était pas l'un c'était
nécessairement l'autre s'avancer devant
les Français et leur dire nous nous
allons faire sauter cette fatalité
entre nous c'était dingue
en tout cas tout le monde considérait
que c'était dingue
et on venait après Marc tu l'a rappelé
mon dossier de très longues décennies de
combat politique parce que nous allons
fêter l'année prochaine enfin dans deux
ans
le centième anniversaire de ce courant
politique
avec la naissance du Parti démocrate
populaire voyez qu'il y a rien qui
change
et c'était déjà Jean-Paul des députés de
notre circonscription qui était là alors
à prier
je ne dis pas qu'il n'y avait pas de
Breton
mais le premier président du groupe du
Parti démocrate populaire il s'appelait
Auguste Champetier de riz mais il était
député des Pyrénées-Atlantiques c'est
comme ça c'est un c'est un fait
[Applaudissements]
et vous savez alors encore une fois
c'est pas pour exclure les Bretons
je peux dire une vacherie
qui s'adresse ni à toi ni à Bruno
Joncourt qui est là ni
à Jimmy
c'est pas pour exclure les Bretons j'ai
trop souvent regretté que les Bretons
s'excluent eux-mêmes
de la construction de ce grand courant
politique dont ils ont été les fleurons
et les piliers et dont parfois ils ont
peut-être pour certains oublier la
vocation
et donc je
c'est une déclaration d'affection à ceux
qui qui ont repris le flambeau
Bruno et qu'il
le lève et qu'il porte Bruno c'est Bruno
Joncourt qui est au deuxième rang
alors vous inquiétez pas c'était pas un
produit local c'est parce qu'après il y
a eu 40 ans de désert et puis après on a
repris le flambeau donc tout ça pour
dire que que qui a quelque chose de très
fort entre nous de très puissant c'est
que
nous sommes engagés dans la même
recherche
nous sommes irrigués de la même sève
comme on dit pour les pour les arbres
et pour moi ça n'est nullement
le
la considération de ce qui s'est passé
nous avons de grands philosophes dans
nos rangs nous avons mais il y a une
chose qui nous caractérise c'est que
nous sommes et nous devons être des
bâtisseurs
le nous voulons construire le nouveau
monde et nous voulons construire un
nouveau monde qui soit j'en parlerai
caractérisé et tout à fait singularisé
par des vertus morales et civiques que
j'essaierai d'aborder rapidement dans ce
discours là
mais je voudrais dire que
avant d'entrer dans dans cet état du
monde je voudrais dire que nous ne
battons pas que pour nous alors je
voudrais sur cette tribune
évoquée les
Ukrainiennes et les Ukrainiens on a vu
avec Oxana
c'était formidable le
la mobilisation d'un peuple
et les maris qui disent
à leur femme partait part avec les
enfants moi je reste pour me battre et
qui réussit à renverser
l'armée qu'on considérait comme l'armée
de terre la plus puissante au monde
alors je dis pas que c'est définitif je
ne dis pas que les combats sont gagnés
je ne dis pas que la guerre est finie
mais quel exemple absolument incroyable
pour faire mentir les Cassandre les
Cassandre mondiales
et les questions de françaises
des gens qui se présentent comme
visionnaire
et qui ont dit des énormités dans dans
cette affaire en expliquant que
il était stupide de croire que
la petite Ukraine d'abord ils
connaissent pas très bien la géographie
c'est ceux qui disent ça mais que la
petite Ukraine allait tenir tête à
l'immense armée russe donc les
ukrainiens et les Ukrainiennes d'abord
les Iraniennes les femmes diront
je trouve
[Applaudissements]
je trouve extraordinaire et
extraordinairement
revivifiant
roboratif et émouvant
parce qu'une jeune femme a été tuée de
manière obscène pour des raisons de
voile comme vous le savez que tant et
tant d'iranienne se lève
et que comme un drapeau elles arbore le
voile enlevé
elle montre quelquefois en le brûlant à
quel point elles sont de la même race de
la même
du même mouvement que cette jeune femme
iranienne assassinée alors si nous
pouvons nous souvenir des femmes
iraniennes dans leur combat et ne pas
les abandonner je trouve que c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais au passage dire un mot alors
elle ne sont pas dans la révolte elles
sont dans l'oppression
des femmes afghanes des petites filles
afghan qui ont interdit d'aller à
l'école des adolescentes afghane qui ont
interdit d'aller à l'université et des
femmes afghane à qui on interdit de
sortir et elles sont pour nous toutes
celles là une des raisons d'engagement
une des raisons de combat et il faut
leur dire
[Applaudissements]
et je veux dire un mot après avoir parlé
de nos frères Ukrainiens je veux dire un
mot de nos frères italien
qui vote aujourd'hui
et qui veut aujourd'hui dans une
circonstance politique dans chacun
d'entre nous savons que
qu'elle est délicate inquiétante et je
veux saluer le mouvement qui sait
constitué autour du Parti démocrate
européen
danger la chance d'être le créateur et
le président et sans drogozzi et son
drogozzi le secrétaire général était la
guerre il a joué un rôle dans la dans
l'édification de cette force là
elle est
remarquable et si elle continue elle
sera considérable un jour alors je salue
nos amis italiens de Italia Viva
[Applaudissements]
j'en viens à l'état du monde qu'on a
abordé plusieurs fois mais qui pour moi
est absolument central
d'abord parce que nous prenons le monde
comme il est
nous essayons avec lucidité de voir où
il en est
c'est-à-dire de prendre la mesure de la
spectaculaire dégradation de l'ordre
mondial
je dis dégradation alors l'ordre
précédent était imparfait je dis pas que
c'était un ordre idéal
mais au moins il était lisible c'est à
dire que tous ceux qui dans le métier et
de décider à partir d'anticipation
savoir ce qui va se passer tout cela
avait au moins des raisons de prendre
des décisions stables alors ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas très commode et pratique
aujourd'hui et je dis de que nous
prenons le monde tel qu'il est en ayant
pour but de le changer à notre mesure à
la mesure de nos forces
alors il y avait trois moteurs dans le
monde d'hier
et ils sont aujourd'hui chacun des trois
en difficulté peut-être pas tous en
panne mais pas loin
il y avait la Chine
qui traverse ou qui est entré dans une
période de profond de
remise en question intérieure
pour deux raisons qui se sont conjugués
l'une et l'autre la première c'est la
démographie
selon les démographes qui peuvent pas se
tromper parce que tous les gens qui vont
mourir sont nés on s'est à peu près à
quel âge ils vont mourir
sauf nous évidemment
on s'est à peu près à quel âge les
choses basculent jusqu'à quel âge on
peut travailler donc c'est une science
exacte la démographie à la différence de
de beaucoup d'entre eux
d'autres sciences sociales
les démographes disent que la Chine va
perdre 500 millions d'habitants dans les
30 ans qui viennent
500 millions d'habitants c'est la
population totale de l'Europe de la
Grande Europe pas seulement de l'Union
européenne
et imaginez ce que ça représente
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que un
peuple est vivant quand sa démographie
est vivante
quand il y a vitalité
et nous avons tort de ne pas y penser
pour nous-mêmes
le plan le Commissariat aux plans
a édité une étude sur la démographie il
y a quelques mois qui essaie d'exprimer
cette inquiétude là pas seulement pour
les autres mais pour nous
et les déséquilibres démographiques
c'est pas seulement le nombre d'un côté
et la rareté de l'autre
c'est qu'il y a des crises économiques
et des violences se guérir qui se
cachent derrière ces déséquilibres la
loi des vases communicants elle n'est
pas vrai qu'en physique elle est vraie
aussi en géopolitique
alors imaginez ce que c'est un peuple
qui a la certitude de perdre plus du
tiers de sa population
par l'âge dans les 30 ans qui viennent
histoire terrible
on ne on ne se rend pas assez compte que
le choix politique que la Chine a fait
enfant unique
c'est une signification qu'on mesure pas
du tout parce que pour nous les familles
enfants uniques c'est classique il y en
a plein et c'est des amis il y a pas de
problème
mais l'enfant unique généralisé ça veut
dire qu'il n'y a plus ni oncle ni tente
ni frère ni sœurs ni cousins nulle part
dans la société chinoise
on est plus relié que verticalement
et
un homme ou une femme un jeune homme ou
une jeune femme à deux parents
point
et bien c'est un changement
anthropologique dont il faut essayer de
prendre la pleine mesure
et vous avez vu que les autorités
chinoises conscient de cette nécessité
démographique l'an dernier où il y a
deux ans on libéralisait le deuxième
enfant et l'an dernier le troisième
enfant et autant qu'on veut
ils ont pas fait davantage d'enfants
pour autant
il n'y a pas eu d'effet
parce que l'imprégnation du modèle de
l'enfant unique sur les consciences sur
la manière d'être et bien ça change
considérablement
ce que les êtres humains vivent et font
ensemble
donc ça c'est la première raison pour
que la Chine soit en situation
d'interrogations il y a une deuxième
raison c'est la politique zéro covid
la Chine a choisi
pour des raisons que les historiens
interrogeront un jour
qu'au lieu de faire ce que nous avons
fait c'est à dire vaccination des bords
et vivre avec
les épidémies résiduelles en Suisse en
ayant ce que j'ai un fils vétérinaire
donc
spécialisé environ ce que on appelle en
virologie l'immunité de troupeau
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle y
compris pour les êtres humains et
souvent c'est justifié et donc
l'immunité de troupeau
et nous arrivons à vivre avec le virus
jusqu'à maintenant peut-être on aura des
mutations plus dangereuses mais on fera
face
notamment parce qu'on a beaucoup
progresser en vaccin et donc ils ont
choisi une autre politique qui est
l'idée
peut-être le fantasme de l'exclusion du
virus
zéro covid
il y a des dizaines de millions de
personnes
et des centaines et milliers de centres
de production qui ont été totalement
arrêtés et toutes les familles
interdites de sortir de chez elle
pendant
des semaines et des mois
et tant de gens enfermés qui ne peuvent
plus sortir même pour chercher du
secours parfois
dans des tours
ça donne des images d'une terrifiante
violence
violence sans violence et parfois
violence avec violence
parce que il faut punir naturellement
tous ceux qui ne respectent pas ces
consignes
et des centaines de milliers
d'occidentaux sont partis de Chine
tous ceux qui faisaient le lien le pont
entre la Chine et l'Occident sont partis
alors est-ce que c'était volontaire
est-ce que ça ne n'était pas les
historiens répondront à cette question
mais ça fait que la Chine qui était sur
une croissance moyenne de quoi 7 8% par
an
va se retrouver cette année proche de
zéro au dernier trimestre ça fait 0,2 la
croissance chinoise alors imaginez ce
que c'est une société qui a les
problèmes que je décris et qui en même
temps
qui a le problème que je décris qui
surfait sur sa croissance pour y
répondre et qui se retrouve tout d'un
coup en situation périlleuse la Chine
les États-Unis je vais pas m'étendre
longuement la puissance américaine elle
existe mais
les ruptures à l'intérieur de la société
américaine le retour de tout le refoulé
le retour y compris de des références à
la guerre de Sécession
et vous savez quel était le sujet de la
guerre de Sécession c'était l'esclavage
c'était c'était la c'était la situation
de des Afro-Américains comme on dit et
ça revient avec une violence et c'est
toute l'histoire du walkisme qui menace
l'Université américaine
et un peu si nous ne faisons pas
attention l'université française
[Applaudissements]
Trump et le le porte-drapeau
de cette remise en cause par les
Américains de l'Amérique
et donc quand vous vous trouvez dans une
dans un pays où une société où les les
forces de
destruction
viennent de sources internes au pays et
que vous n'avez pas les mécanismes
immunitaires pour y répondre alors c'est
un pays qui est en danger et au risque
et je pense avec avec beaucoup
d'affections au peuple américain partie
de de ma famille est américaine donc
tout ça est la famille de ma femme pour
être exacte et donc tout ça est
tout ça est impressionnant et l'Europe
qui était qui devrait être
un facteur de stabilité de dynamisme
l'Europe elle se trouve aux prises avec
la guerre en Ukraine avec les
conséquences du choix désastreux que les
hommes politiques allemands ont fait de
se mettre entièrement dans la dépendance
de Poutine et du gaz russe
un jour interroger les raisons qui ont
fait que nombre de politiques allemands
ont favorisé pousser dans le sens de
cette politique de dépendance au gaz
russe et quand on regarde l'évolution
professionnelle
de ceux qui ont exercé ses
responsabilités on a quelques
inquiétudes mais l'Allemagne malade
c'est le rhum malade
et donc on a les trois les trois
facteurs les trois moteurs qui sont en
situation périlleuse et c'est un très
grand danger pour nous dans ce monde-là
c'est
la France
qui doit assumer une mission c'est la
mission de reconstruction de l'ordre
mondiale
un ordre le plus équilibré qu'on puisse
trouver et nous avons des
responsabilités
le discours du président de la
République à l'ONU a été pour la France
un moment de de reconnaissance
un moment d'influence
un moment de de où on a été fier moi
j'ai été fier d'écouter ce discours
parce que tout d'un coup tout ce qui
était des questions
brumesuses dans l'ordre international
dans la situation de chacun des pays
dans les relations avec chacun des pays
tout ça est devenu
parfaitement lisible et parfaitement
juste à entendre
et donc le la France joue un rôle et ce
que le président de la République a dit
de la manière la plus explicite
ce qu'il a dit c'était que nous avions
des responsabilités les uns chez les
autres
que les pays
n'étaient pas enfermés dans leur univers
de frontières nationales
qu'il ne pouvait pas faire ce qu'il
voulait qu'il y avait entre les pays
selon une charte de valeur
parfaitement claire qui avait des choses
inacceptables et que nous n'accepterions
pas et que nous n'acceptons pas et pour
moi c'est très très important dans
l'histoire il y a eu
quelque chose qui s'est qui s'est passé
à la Société des Nations
en
1934 si je me trompe pas
il y avait un juif
qui a porté plainte devant la Société
des nations
en dénonçant il a réussi à passer les
filtres successifs en dénonçant les
exactions les les humiliations les
les attentats dont c'est
corrélieionnaires étaient victimes dans
le monde nazi on est très tôt dans
l'histoire
et celui qui représente le gouvernement
national socialiste
c'est gobels
à la Société des Nations et gabbels
monte à la tribune
et il n'est pas du tout les accusations
et il dit cette phrase que nous avons
tous en mémoire il dit Charbonnier et
maître chez soi
nous ferons je cite à peu près
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se passe
je cite à peu près exactement la phrase
de gobels il dit Charbonnier et maître
chez soi nous ferons ce que nous voulons
de nos communistes de nos socialistes et
de nos juifs
et personne ne répond
et René Cassin qui assistait à cette
séance le très grand juriste René Cassin
celui qui va faire
les institutions et la Charte des droits
de 45 et 6 René Cassin dit c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai compris que
l'humanité courait à sa perte
parce que la Société des Nations
personne n'a contredit gobels et ce que
j'aime dans la période notamment venant
des dirigeants français c'est qu'au lieu
d'accepter l'inacceptable ils sont
montés à la tribune pour dire que nous
ne l'accepterions jamais depuis le
premier jour Jean-Yves Le Drian de la
rappeler hier jusqu'au discours à l'ONU
et ça mérite qu'on soit fier
alors
je crois que la France serait mieux
armée que les autres
pourrait être mieux armé que les autres
parce qu'elle est un pays magnifiquement
équipé avec un contrat social dans tous
nous savons à quel point il est rare
dans le monde depuis l'école maternelle
jusqu'au collège de France depuis le
dispensaire du coin de la rue jusqu'au
plus grands hôpitaux quel que soit la
situation sociale de ceux qui sont
atteints par la maladie
doté d'une capacité d'indépendance
marque d'abord de souveraineté
alimentaire et ça compte
de souveraineté énergétique grâce à la
réorientation qui avait fait qui a été
faite et nous y avons joué un petit rôle
sur la production d'électricité
nucléaire
dont j'espère que d'ici quatre mois les
plus les plus grands embêtements seront
effacés
on est
formidablement
outillés pour faire face mais
mais la division
constante perpétuelle voulu alimenter
exciter
et malheureusement une menace sur notre
destin
alors je voudrais je voudrais m'arrêter
une seconde à ça à cette idée
ces forces de division et de détestation
les femmes contre les hommes
la couleur de peau contre l'autre
couleur de peau
la classe sociale contre d'autres
classes sociales
la danse du scalp autour des supposés
riches
la mise en accusation publique
sur des affaires privées par des
responsables politiques qui vont à la
télévision pour
pointer du doigt et clouer au pylori
sans avoir me semble-t-il de
preuves
indiscutables en disant même qu'il y a
rien de pénalement répréhensible
la dénonciation publique
les salariés contre les patrons les
salariés contre les entreprises tout ça
ce sont ces forces de division ça c'est
un nom c'est la guerre de tous contre
tous
et notre mission
contre la société d'affrontement c'est
de construire une autre société un autre
projet d'avenir que j'appelle la société
d'harmonie une société une cité
harmonieuse à part une cité où il y a
plus aucune difficulté mais une cité
dans laquelle on affirme son trembler
que il y a beaucoup de femmes qui se
sont pas prises dans la guerre des
femmes contre les hommes
ils sont pas tous formidables
on en sait quelque chose
mais il n'y a pas de guerre
il y a un destin à construire ensemble
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
pris dans la guerre des salariés contre
les patrons parce qu'ils savent que s'il
n'y a pas d'entreprise il y aura pas de
salariés on pourra pas avancer et je
vous rappelle qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui
demandent qu'on requalifie leur contrat
de travail quand ils sont indépendants
en contrat de salariés
et puis il y a beaucoup de gens nous en
sommes
permettez-moi de dire en votre nom que
j'en suis qui considère que le
pluralisme des religions ne doit pas
entraîner de guerre de religion
[Applaudissements]
et notre affirmation ici c'est que
contrairement à ces assez feux de
broussailles qu'on allume constamment et
dont on sait les dégâts qu'ils peuvent
faire on l'a vu
assez souvent ces temps-ci contre tout
cela nous nous pensons que nous pouvons
vivre ensemble que nous pouvons et que
nous devons vivre ensemble et tel est
notre projet
tel est notre résistance
telle est notre volonté de ne pas nous
laisser entraîner dans cet affrontement
de de division qui dérivent en haine
nous voulons construire ensemble le
monde meilleur que nous attendons
[Applaudissements]
alors
ne me prenez pas pour un idéaliste
déjanté
je sais que la division est dans la
nature humaine c'est même dans
l'étymologie vous savez que le mot
diable
c'est ça vient du grec diabolosse et
diabolosse ça veut dire le diviseur
et il n'est pas un militant
d'associations de pêche à la ligne
où de de joueurs de bridge je parle même
pas des associations sportives et encore
moins des associations culturelles il y
a pas un engagé qui ne sache que tout le
temps la division est présente et c'est
Jules César qui disait ça il disait dans
les villages gaulois il y a toujours au
moins trois parties un pour un contre et
celui qui est contre les deux autres
et c'est vrai la dernière partie de la
phrase c'est moi qui l'ai inventé mais
qu'il y ait toujours au moins trois
parties 13 par test ça c'est de Jules
César c'est dans la guerre des Gaules
vous pouvez le vérifier et donc je sais
très bien la nature humaine mais
nous nous pensons alors c'est c'est là
que nous entend dans notre
philosophie politique
dans ce qui nous fait avancer et vivre
ensemble nous nous pensons qu'il y a des
stratégies
pour réduire les divisions et rendre le
monde plus vivable et le moyen de
réduire les divisions et de rendre le
monde plus vivable ça s'appelle
démocratie la démocratie c'est ceux qui
transforme les n et les détestations
en pluralisme
on s'affronte on n'est pas du même avis
on est différent mais après on peut
vivre ensemble
et donc cette cette manière de de ne pas
nier les divisions et l'esprit diviseur
mais de les sublimer ou de les
métaboliser c'est évidemment très
important et il y a des techniques
il y en a plusieurs je trouve que ça
tombe bien il y a une première technique
qui est
de
penser l'avenir dans des plans
quand j'ai je me suis battu pendant des
décennies vous en êtes témoin pour
essayer de faire revivre cette idée de
plan en France
le plan c'est la capacité de faire le
constat de la situation dans laquelle on
se trouve de désigner l'avenir qu'on
compte atteindre et de marquer des
étapes pour y parvenir
c'est ce qu'a fait Jean Monnet après la
guerre vous savez que le général de
Gaulle à propos du plan disait l'ardente
obligation du plan
ardente obligation du plan alors pendant
vous avez des témoins j'ai été fortement
moqué pendant grand nombre d'années et
pas mal de décennies parce que je
défendais cette idée et puis le
président de la République a bien voulu
dire que
qu'après tout on vérifié dans le covid
que c'est parce qu'on n'avait pas eu des
plans sur un très grand nombre
d'équipements de de
dispositifs médicaux qu'on était dans la
situation où on était alors il m'a dit
essayer de le recréer
et on l'a et on l'a fait
et tout d'un coup alors je vous passe
les Ladis c'était le retour au gosse
plan stalinien léninistes je sais pas
quoi enfin on a on a lu tout ça c'est
sous des plumes autorisées
et deux ans après on ne parle plus que
du plan dans tous les domaines de
l'action publique on veut planifier
écologiquement veut planifier
médicalement on veut planifier
j'ai un petit coup de victoire quand je
quand je vois ça
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai l'habitude
Edgar Faure
que vous savez le l'homme des tas de la
de la Quatrième République était début
de la 5e il a écrit ses mémoires et le
titre des mémoires d'elgaffort c'est
avoir toujours raison c'est un grand
torse
voilà il y a des parents comme ça et
donc
et donc
ça c'est la c'est la première option qui
permet en effet
que le concert des opinions puissent
référer à quelque chose qu'on partage
pour l'avenir ça n'est pas immédiatement
dans l'actualité que se situe
l'essentiel de l'action publique c'est
dans le long terme et il met souvent
arrivé de dire les Chinois je j'observe
beaucoup comment ne pas observer un
milliard 400 millions de personnes et un
régime comme il y en a jamais eu
les Chinois résonnent à 30 ans c'est
leur horizon de temps nous si on
raisonne à 30 jours
c'est qu'il y a vraiment des gens qui
ont de la vision
je ne plaisante pas je dis ça avec
tristesse parce que la vérité c'est que
c'est les sondages qui conduisent
l'action publique je dis souvent c'est
pas les gouvernants qui gouvernent c'est
l'opinion qui gouverne au travers de ce
que les gouvernants ressentent de ces
attentes c'est pourquoi vous avez chacun
chacune d'entre vous toi et toi vous
avez des responsabilités majeures dans
le destin du pays pas seulement parce
que vous votez mais parce que vous
transformez la vision de ceux qui vous
entourent
c'est un militantisme de tous les jours
de conviction à faire à faire partager
donc ça c'est la première c'est la
première idée il y a une deuxième idée
que le Président de la République a eu
et ça je n'y étais pour rien c'était
cette idée
de concertation en continu sur les
fondamentaux du pays qu'il a appelé
refondation Conseil national de la
refondation pour faire écho au Conseil
national de la Résistance bien entendu
c'est une idée très fructueuse au début
j'étais pas enthousiaste parce qu'on
parlait de tirage au sort et le tirage
au sort c'est pas quelque chose dans
quoi je me reconnais je l'avoue
humblement il y a des débats entre nous
Erwan je sais pas où il est passé
Erwan Balan il est là-bas on a des
débats entre nous sur ce sur ce sujet
mais quand le président de la République
a précisé qu'il s'agissait de faire
représenter toutes les forces sociales
les entreprises les syndicats les
mouvements des élus les grandes les
grandes associations d'élus les
associations de jeunesse les
associations
écologistes et de les inviter à poser
ensemble les problèmes de notre avenir
alors là c'est devenu beaucoup plus
intéressant et comme de surcroît il m'a
proposé peut-être un prudemment de
prendre une de prendre une
responsabilité dans d'organisation dans
dans ce grand mouvement alors là je
trouve que c'est intéressant faire
précéder
ouvrez les guillemets faire précéder
toutes les grandes réformes par un
travail de concertation
de consultation de croisement des
convictions et des expériences et après
ça peut aller vite j'en dirai un mot et
après seulement entrer dans la partie
décisionnelle et législative des
réformes alors il me semble que là nous
sommes dans la démocratie au sens propre
du terme pas dans la démocratie qui
suppose que les uns vont trancher contre
les autres par un passage en force et
donc je pense qu'il est légitime et
important que nous défendions cette
vision alors naturellement je le fais
sur les retraites je vais vous dire deux
choses sur les retraites 3
1 je considère que la réforme est
indispensable pour trouver un équilibre
pour les régimes de retraite dans le
futur et dans le long terme je considère
que c'est indispensable vital
de
je suis persuadé qu'un très nom un très
grand nombre de Français sont persuadés
de cette nécessité parce qu'il voit bien
ce qu'il en est des problèmes
démographiques il y a beaucoup plus de
gens à la retraite qu'autrefois par
rapport aux gens qui travaillent et qui
fournissent le versement des pensions
tous les mois persuadé de ça
mais trois
personne ne leur donne des éléments
précis sur cette affaire le nombre
d'amis d'amis qui me disent mais
François est-ce que c'est bien utile
parce qu'il y a des rapports du corps
qui disent que c'est pas vrai que c'est
pas nécessaire que les régimes sont
équilibrés que ça n'est pas une
nécessité que c'est pas fait pour ça
mais pour je suis absolument certain
qu'on peut établir des éléments
indiscutables les données à connaître
aux Français et aux forces sociales qui
organisent les français pour que chacun
se forme sa conviction sur ce sujet et
ça ne prend pas des années
on me dit mais ça fait des années qu'on
discute on discute peut-être mais les
Français n'en savent rien
autour de vous aucun de ces éléments
n'est connu combien ça coûte combien ça
peut durer avant que on ne mette en
cause le paiement des pensions mais
c'est des éléments qu'on doit aux
citoyens c'est même pas que qu'on doit
leur faire plaisir
c'est que c'est un devoir cantonné
gouvernant de partager les raisons de
l'action avec ceux qui vous ont donné la
mission de les gouverner
[Applaudissements]
alors j'entends des critiques qui disent
mais ça va traîner on ne fera plus rien
je me permets de signaler que en
refusant cette méthode on a bloqué les
réformes pendant des décennies j'étais
au gouvernement au moment du plan Juppé
et quelques heures d'entre vous étaient
à la fondation de force démocrate
pendant les grandes grèves de cet hiver
là à Lyon on avait traversé la France en
stop si j'ose dire tous en voiture parce
que tous les transports en commun
étaient bloqués au mois de décembre au
mois de décembre
1995 et donc
c'est évident c'est évident pour moi que
et puis vous prenez les réformes
successives jusqu'à la dernière sous le
gouvernement Édouard Philippe
tous ces bloqué
j'avais dit au moment des gilets jaunes
pardons de me citer
je sentais venir les gilets jaunes j'ai
fait une interview un peu dans le genre
de
ces jours-ci
pour dire attention sur la taxe carbone
il faut trouver un moyen d'adaptation
parce que les plus pauvres ne supportent
plus la montée
en flèche du prix du carburant et
cherchons une adaptation qui permette de
faire varier la taxe carbone en fonction
du prix du brut une idée qui avait déjà
été évoquée
et j'avais dit on ne gouverne pas contre
le peuple je suis absolument persuadé de
ça
le les gouvernants
portent des réformes elles sont souvent
bien inspirées mais s'ils n'ont pas le
soutien du peuple qui les a élus ces
réformes sont bloquées et ne passent pas
parce que la société est tellement
éruptive tellement
capable de s'enflammer
et même de violence on l'a vu à des
moments dont nous avons tous la mémoire
la société est tellement éruptive
qu'il faut se donner pour objectif de la
convaincre avant de l'entraîner
nous nos concitoyens sont tous sur les
réseaux sociaux ils suivent tous les
télés en continu ils ont besoin
d'éléments du choix et le travail que
nous avons à faire dans le conseil de la
refondation ou tout autre organisme qui
traitera de cette question des retraites
nous pouvons le faire très vite moi je
dis quatre mois suffisent
quatre mois ça nous porte au début de
l'année 2023 le président de la
République a dit je veux que cette
réforme soit
[Musique]
en place
à l'été 2023 on est dans on est dans
l'agenda
et s'il faut une fois que le débat a eu
lieu qu'on a partagé les raisons avec
les citoyens qu'on a montré quel était
l'inspiration du pouvoir
parce que c'est pas une réforme pour les
gouvernants c'est pas une réforme pour
les partis politiques de la majorité
c'est pas une réforme pour un avantage
idéologique c'est une réforme pour les
français pour continuer à payer les
pensions même quand la société française
et puis c'est pas seulement une réforme
budgétaire
c'est une réforme de société
la retraite j'en ai parlé avec plusieurs
d'entre vous pendant ces jours-ci
la retraite pour une femme pour un homme
c'est un moment très important d'entrer
dans une nouvelle manière de vivre
et il arrive qu'à l'âge de la retraite
on soit usé
moi je
pense beaucoup
aux jeunes femmes qui travaillent aux
jeunes ou parfois moins jeunes femmes
qui travaillent au CCAS
dans ma ville
et qui doivent lever des personnes âgées
qui parfois pèsent 90 kg
et parfois plus
et alors bien sûr elles ont
ce qu'on appelle des affections
muscles squelettiques
mal au dos
elles ont peuvent plus je pense toujours
ça dans les rues de Paris il y a assez
souvent des ouvriers qui réparent les
trottoirs avec du goudron liquide
brûlant ils ont une taloche et il
taloche le goudron liquide dans une
température qui doit avoisiner les 60
degrés avec les vapeurs de goudron
moi je vais pas leur demander de
rester jusqu'à 65 ans dans ses activités
là alors ça veut dire deux choses
1 l'âge de la retraite il est fonction
de la vie de chacun
et j'aimerais qu'il soit fonction de son
choix
le la retraite choisie vous savez que je
me suis battu beaucoup pour la retraite
par point c'était l'idée que chacun
choisit son départ à la retraite
et on peut tout à fait imaginer
en
aidant à ce choix
d'inciter à l'allongement du travail
mais l'incitation
ça respecte la respecte la liberté de
chacun par exemple j'ai souvent proposé
l'idée qu'on puisse
continuer à travailler en touchant une
partie de sa retraite
vous avez un revenu vous pouvez
continuer le travail et ça arrive pour
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont en
pleine forme au moment de prendre sa
retraite je veux dire on a imaginé à
inventer
des approches nouvelles
très souvent on dit mais on a discuté de
ça pendant des années
est-ce qu'on a exploré toutes les pistes
je ne le crois pas et c'est pourquoi je
dis prenons un temps court dans lequel
on fera deux choses ensemble
premièrement on partagera des éléments
factuels indiscutables on se mettra
d'accord si on peut se mettre d'accord
s'aperçois déjà deux ou trois sujets sur
lesquels il y aura des interprétations
différentes mais si les chiffres sont
les chiffres on peut arriver à les
établir on se mettra d'accord et on
regardera de bonnes foi si on peut
imaginer des sorties plus plus positives
plus plus respectueuse de ce que nous
avons voulu faire après tout vous avez
les parlementaires discutés pendant des
mois et des mois
sur
Nicolas sur la loi précédente sur les
retraites
on n'est pas aux pièces prendre trois ou
quatre mois pour réfléchir ensemble
mettre sur la table des faits et des
options et des propositions moi je pense
que ça serait bon pas seulement pour la
paix civile
ça compte mais pour la réforme elle-même
parce que
derrière tout ça
il n'y a pas que la question des
retraites il y a la question de la
méthode de réforme qu'on peut suivre
pour le pays moi je crois qu'on n'a pas
trouvé la clé
et qu'avec cette idée qui est je
rappelle celle du président de la
République
qu'on va partager les éléments
essentiels qui nourrissent la décision
je pense qu'on fait un pas décisif dans
une méthode de réforme qui sera plus
respectueuse plus moderne et plus
efficace parce qu'on arrivera à la
réforme alors que autrement on bloquera
[Applaudissements]
alors cette idée d'une méthode de
réformisme démocratique je la crois
fructueuse
je pense que cette manière de
reconnaître
dans toute sa légitimité
le
les idées de chacun la démarche de
chacun derrière tout ça il y a quelque
chose d'extrêmement précieux qui pour
moi est une redéfinition de la
démocratie telle que nous l'avons vécu
j'ai mis très longtemps à comprendre que
je croyais ce que je vais vous dire je
savais pas ce que je croyais j'avais
l'impression que je croyais la même
chose que les autres et puis j'ai fini
par penser que c'était pas vrai
je pense que la démocratie
ce n'est pas ce que tout le monde croit
parce que tout le monde croit que la
démocratie s'est fait triompher ses
opinions sur les opinions des autres
et moi je crois tout à l'heure Marc la
évoqué je pense que la vraie démocratie
c'est pas ça la vraie démocratie c'est
faire reconnaître la légitimité de son
opinion tout en acceptant la légitimité
des opinions des autres
[Applaudissements]
et ce que j'appelle la symphonie
démocratique chaque instrument joue son
rôle dans le la mélodie qu'on va émettre
ensemble je pense que c'est très
précieux si l'on y réfléchit et je pense
que ça s'adapte
à tous les domaines qu'on a évoqué ici
comme des domaines en crise je pense que
ça s'adapte à l'école
je suis persuadé depuis des années
beaucoup d'années
que il y a une richesse incroyable
dans
les femmes et les hommes qui sont des
enseignants
chacun d'entre eux
chacun d'entre eux devant sa classe il
trouve des méthodes il invente il fait
progresser les élèves et certains jours
il est content et d'autres pas et ceux
qui font progresser leurs élèves il y en
a plein
sauf que personne ne les repère
et la méthode fonctionnement classique
du ministère de l'Éducation
c'est
on donne des instructions au sommet
et on les fait appliquer à la base on
regarde pas ce qui se passe dans les
classes on impose une démarche qui est
venue du sommet et moi je crois le
contraire je crois à la liberté
pédagogique et je crois à la capacité de
repérer les réussites pour que elle
fasse tache d'huile pour qu'elle se
répandent et
je crois à ça dans le domaine de la
santé j'étais très content d'entendre
François Braun le ministre de la santé
parce qu'il a dit une chose que je
considère comme essentiel depuis
longtemps
qui faisait partie des programmes que
nous avons défendus devant les Français
il a dit
bien sûr on peut pas multiplier les
médecins mais on peut augmenter le temps
médical le nombre d'heures que les
médecins sont obligés de passer pour
remplir de la paperasse et qui et qui
leur fait d'une certaine manière
désespérée de leur métier on peut
remédier à ça j'étais très content que
le ministre de la Santé le dise c'est
partir du terrain en reconnaître la
légitimité pour imposer des réformes
pour l'ensemble du pays
[Applaudissements]
et donc cette cette vision nouvelle que
je crois nécessaire d'une démocratie qui
est une démocratie fondée sur la
reconnaissance réciproque je suis frappé
de ça tout les jours dans mes dans mes
fonctions locales de maire de animateur
local de et national
le problème le plus important de la
société dans laquelle nous vivons le
problème le plus important c'est la
reconnaissance tout le monde se sent
privé de reconnaissance dans son métier
dans son corps d'état dans dans sa
manière de participer au débat public et
au fond les gilets jaunes disaient pas
autre chose
avec les excès qui vont avec
et notamment chacun des citoyens et des
citoyens professionnels qui se trouve en
but aux décisions
des gouvernants qui concernent son état
tout son sentiment que personne ne les
écoute jamais
et je vais vous dire quelque chose
en plus je crois que c'est vrai
que le
la faculté d'écoute cette émoussée
que d'une certaine manière la
multiplication des réseaux
d'informations
fait que on écoute plus les gens qui
sont enracinés sur le terrain
et bâtir une société de la
reconnaissance
plus exactement bâtir une société qui
vise à devenir harmonieuse par la
reconnaissance
vers un projet qui est à la dimension du
siècle c'est un projet qui est à la
dimension de notre famille et je vous
propose de connaissez de le faire
construire ou de le construire ensemble
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans nos campagnes
qui
que dans nos bras
[Musique]
et si on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]